As we mentioned in the previous video, visual cues are
one of the main ingredients to an effective visualization. In the
next couple of videos, we'll cover some of the main
visual cues that you can use to represent data in your
charts. The first one that we're going to discuss is
position. When using position as a visual cue, you compute value
by looking at the position of a point compared to
the position of others in the same space or coordinate system.
Here, this would translate to this point's x and
y coordinate. Position is useful in coding because it
takes up less space than other visual cues. It's
really space efficient. Each data point is simply represented as
a dot. Also, points often have the same size
which allows you to easily identify trends, clusters, and outliers
by plotting all of your data at once. But
if you have too many data points in your plot,
it can be a challenge to identify what each
point represents. For example, imagine that this chart were covered
with dozens of green dots just like this one. It
might be hard for us to identify individual dots and
really understand what they mean, or what day do they
correspond to. Another commonly used visual cue is length, which
is often encountered in the form of bar charts. The
length of a bar indicates the intensity or value of
your data point. For example, the longer the bar,
the greater the absolute value. One more encoding that's
very common is angle. Angle ranges from 0 to
360 degrees on a circle. Angles are commonly used to
represent parts of a whole. A pie chart is
a really common example of this. The sum of
the wedges in this pie complete a circle and
give us 360 degrees. One negative aspect to using angles
as a visual encoding is that human eyes can have a
difficult time differentiating angles. For example,
25 degrees and 30 degrees may
look very similar. Because of this, angle is an encoding that you
may want to avoid if you're trying to show very small differences.